sempé c'est vous qui avez donné à
nicolas son visage sa silhouette sa
taille son âge nicolas c'est un petit
garçon est ce que c'est un personnage
c'est un personnage dès l'instant où les
des cinémas français de rénovation comme
bécassine par exemple non c'était en
fait nicolas est le prototype mais en
fait c'est un groupe d'enfants surtout
un groupe d'enfants c'est
c'est dit avec ses petits copains mais
nicolas ne ressemble ressemble en fait à
peu près tous les les enfants que je
dessine un général ou à toul et la façon
dont je me figure que sont faits les
enfants dia commencé c'est vous c'est
vous
c'est à dire sempéré commencé à faire
des dessins humoristiques dans
lesquelles il y avait un petit garçon
brun qui l'a nommé nicolas après quoi
nous l'avons repris ensemble sous une
autre forme nous l'avons abandonné et
nous l'avons définitivement repris sous
sa forme actuelle il ya de cela environ
trois heures il faut dire que c'est un
enfant qui vit parmi les enfants c'est
pas un enfant qui vit dans le monde des
adultes non mais c'est à dire que c'est
un enfant qui vit lui les enfants dès
l'instant où il toujours en classe
il a uniquement des enfants des amis de
son âge mais c'est un enfant qui vit
quand même avec ses parents c'est pas le
moyen pour vous de faire une description
narquoise ou
renommés du monde et qu'ils annulent
ne fait pas de mots d'enfant donc voilà
je vous mets jamais c'est lui qui
raconte l'histoire c'est lui qui raconte
l'histoire et il le raconte comme me le
racontera un enfant c'est à dire sans
faire dé mode en forêt vous dites cdc
l'islande en face c'est un groupe
d'enfants nicolas effectivement ils sont
multiples ils se ressemblent un peu tout
simplement parce que les dessins sont
petit on ne va pas bien
physiquement ils se ressemblent oui
parce que savait que en fait quand les
enfants sont en couple est assez
difficile de distinguer un ou des amis
qui lui qu'il est un gros nez ce qui est
rare chez les enfants qu'il est parfois
ils ont les cheveux roux
non mais ce sont des déserts fois qu'ils
se ressemblent pas ce que c'est on a
essayé de faire en réalité uniquement la
vie d'un groupe d'enfants pas du tout de
type et pour en faire un personnage qui
restera qui toute sa vie aura toujours
les nems bretelles mais que tout ça soit
pas les personnages ils ont tous mes
mais il à dire des caractères bien bien
précis on peut par exemple on joue
beaucoup il joue beaucoup au football
avec n'importe quoi et n'importe quoi
oui parce que je pense que tous les
enfants jouent au football n'importe
quoi et puis n'importe quand ça
caractère essentiel de l'enfant de nis
ah oui en ce qui concerne l'eau dit
absolument pour vous cette amante est le
ballon de football la plus regardée en
vidéo dès l'instant où un enfant est
capable de taper sur un ballon ils
commencent déjà à m'intéresser vous faut
batailler sur les micros non mais ça je
vous propose
il ya comme une autre autre constante a
eu à payer oui les enfants chez toujours
il se bat souvent les enfants adorent
pas beaucoup dans ce livre il se bat
beaucoup mais il adore se battre il se
bat comme se battre les enfants c'est à
dire sans colère ils se font jamais de
mal réellement et pendant qu'ils se
battent ils s'amusent beaucoup
d'ailleurs chaque fois fait le
surveillant vient interrompre une des
leurs nombreuses bagarres ils se
plaignent parce que juste 30 ans
commencé à rigoler des styles on vient
vous interrompre jusque dans les récrés
finalement il se passe on attendait
toujours qu'il se passe quelque chose
oui parce que dans une récré et il se
passe beaucoup de choses mais jamais ce
que les enfants prévoit les enfants
descendent à la récré à la récréation
avec des buts enfin ils vont faire des
choses extraordinaires et bon jouer au
football du mot ils vont faire un
journal ils vont faire des tas de choses
et finalement ils ne font rien pour
faire quelque chose il faut déjà choisir
un chef bien que le fait de choisir un
chef ça déclenche immédiatement une
bagarre et ainsi de suite la récréation
qui est très courte se passant plusieurs
bagarres l'intervention du surveillant
et on reprendra la prochaine et c'est ça
qui laisse surveillance et le bouillon
c'est le bouillant oui on l'appelle le
bouillon parce qu'il dit toujours
regardez moi bien dans les yeux et dans
les yeux il ya le bouillon d'après
nicolas son écran il y avait aux yeux
c'est ça on décolle pas vraiment les
copains et à au moins quatre en tout cas
qui ont du
caractère très précis et bien il ya un
os est c'est le meilleur copain nicolas
celui qui est de tous les coups elle
c'était un gros c'est un gros qui mange
tout le temps et quand on lui serre la
main il est toujours collante la main ce
qu'il ya toujours des conflits
il y à un refuse dont le papa est agent
de police et qui a toujours sur lui un
sifflet roulettes qui est un souvenir de
famille et c'est pour ça qu'il est
toujours arbitres dans les matchs de
football ça provoque des histoires parce
qu'il est arbitré joueurs en même temps
et la terrasse à favoriser son camp il
ya un claude terre clotaire c'est le
dernier de la classe il est toujours
dernier chaque fois qu'il est interrogé
les privés de récréation quand il amène
son livret scolaire il est privé de
télévision il est privé de cinéma et
quand le directeur legrand d'il divo
parents se prive de tout pour donner une
éducation c'est une famille ou en
afrique beaucoup
il ya eu il ya eu eux deux c'est le plus
fort et c'est le costaud de la bande il
adore donner des coups de poing sur le
nez des coupes et on aime autant ne pas
se battre avec c'est le seul avec lequel
on se bat le mans mais aussi les lieux
de l'action santé je crois que le
terrain règles l'école de bourg bien sûr
ensuite le terrain vague et ensuite je
n'ai pas de deux le chemin qu'il ya
entre l'école et la maison c'est à dire
la rue il ya sûrement entre les deux
axiaux egalgi confus c'est oui mais leur
face à financer les partis dans les
créations par des quand il a visité un
musée c'est le jeudi et le jeudi en
général il n'y a pas classe il n'y a pas
d'école wardrecques alors c'est la
grande récréation yade est aussi le
docteur c'est une bonne chose mais mon
cher confrère rené goscinny là vous en
parlait du test par une envie de rester
et bien aimé tester
on a annoncé aux enfants qu'ils allaient
passer un test un test médical ils n'ont
pas très bien compris de quoi il s'agit
enfin ils ont compris qu'ils allaient
faire des dessins pour prouver qu'il
n'était pas fou alors ils se sont
retrouvés aujourd'hui
au dispensaire avec leurs mamans et des
avis on les déshabille et aussitôt il
commence à voir les réactions et
commence à voir les réactions qu'on a
dans ces cas là c'est à dire un petit
gosse qui est tout nu commence à montrer
ses biceps aux autres gosses quand ils
vont se peser qui se fait sur la balance
aussitôt il faut qu'un et deux à la fois
sur une balance enfin il faut à peu près
tout ce qu'on peut faire dans ces cas là
le médecin bien sûr commence à en avoir
assez et alors c'est après qu'on leur
fait faire ses fameux dessin pour voir
j'imagine le sentimental
que tout dépend parce que tout dépend du
caractère de chaque personnage mais je
crois qu'elle cesse de dessiner
cassoulet parce qu'il aime beaucoup
mangé les autres dessine pas mal de
choses mais je crois que c'est canal ça
c'est de signer suivant uniquement
suivants sont en théorie à niort dessine
agnant qui est le premier de la glace
est le chouchou de la maîtresse dessine
la carte de france avec les départements
les nicolas un gâteau clotaire le
dessine rien parce qu'il n'a rien
préparé toujours derniers miles pour le
test et le médecin quand il s'en vend
lui il dessine des révolvers vous avez
des enfants n'ont absolument pas
logiciels et mater je n'ai pas d'enfant
et vous vous attendez c'était à votre
avis c'est un cetain livres pour parents
donc plutôt
notre savoir faire je crois que c'est un
livre pour les parents qu'en dix ans des
enfants et pour les enfants quand dix
ans des parents je crois enfin côté
style on parle de gens je crois que non
mais on n'a pas cherché à faire un livre
soit pour les avis se sont sauf pour les
enfants
il est difficile de dire à partir de
quel âge et jusqu'à quel âge on va faire
rire quand on essaie de faire quelque
chose qui est amusant sont des souvenirs
d'enfance qui vous ont fait dessiner
nicolas
très souvent très souvent quand même
parce que je conserve assez bon souvenir
de lui
deux maisons des scolaires je me suis
bien amusé et j'ai bien sûr été alors
que jamais rester les enfants pour ça
c'est un livre c'est un livre l'humour
et ce qui tombe bien c'est que ces
tarifs sont très très amusant les
montois qu'il existe d'autres biens pour
les amplis
[Musique]